vamos a suponer que el día de hoy
armando tiene 18 años armando tiene 18
años y también vamos a suponer que diana
el día de hoy tiene solamente 2 años es
una pequeña bebé solamente tiene dos
años ahora bien lo que me quiero
preguntar en este vídeo es en cuántos
años en cuántos años
en cuántos años esté armando va a tener
el triple de edad que diana
en cuantos años armando tendrá tres
veces la edad de diana el triple de edad
que diana y bueno sería muy bueno que en
este momento para usar es el vídeo para
intentarlo por ti mismo porque ya viene
la solución la solución porque fíjate
bien lo que nos preguntamos es en
cuántos años armando va a tener el
triple de edad que tiene en cuántos años
así que vamos a definir ayer como la
cantidad de años que nos faltan para que
esto ocurra y es igual a los años en los
cuales armando va a tener el triple de
edad que diana justo y es lo que estamos
buscando es decir en cuántos años
armando va a tener el triple de edad que
diana muy bien y qué pasa en esta
cantidad de años en años pues vamos a
ver en diez años qué es lo que va a
pasar con mis dos personajes en el año
entonces cómo van a estar sus edades
bueno pues fijémonos primero en armando
armando actualmente tiene 18 años
entonces armando tiene 18 años y en 10
años pues va a tener diez años más
entonces al mando va a tener 18 más años
entonces armando en 10 años va a tener
18 más años y qué pasa con diana bueno
bien actualmente tiene 2 añitos pero en
10 años diana va a tener dos más años es
decir va a estar diez años más grande
diana va a tener dos más años armando 18
más 10 años y es hora de preguntarnos
pues precisamente eso que nos preguntan
lo que queremos es saber pero con una
cierta condición nos dicen que estamos
buscando una y una cantidad de años
tales que la edad de armando sea el
triple que la edad de diana es decir 18
más y es igual a 3 por
más bien este 3 que está multiplicando
al 2 + james representa el triple de la
edad de diana pero ojo no en el día de
hoy sino en 10 años por lo tanto me
queda 18 más y es igual a 3 que
multiplicados + james y lo único que hay
que hacer es solucionar esta ecuación te
das cuenta no nos estamos fijando qué es
lo que pasa ahorita lo que no estamos
fijando es qué va a pasar en 10 años y
en 10 años lo que queremos es que pase
el triple y por lo tanto voy a
distribuir este 3 multiplicando por todo
lo que está dentro del paréntesis me
queda 3 por 2 6 más 3 por james 3 bien
entonces tengo la ecuación 18 más bien
es igual a 6 más 3 bien y a continuación
lo que voy a hacer es despejar ayer y
para resolver esta ecuación lo primero
que voy a hacer es pasar esta y del otro
lado de la ecuación y para pasarla del
otro lado de la ecuación lo que voy a
hacer estaría de ambos lados de la
ecuación y que me va a quedar bueno 18
may efe - james pues estas 2 evans se
cancelan y solamente me queda 18 18 es
igual a 6 + 3g menos 100 3g menos james
es dos veces bien y bueno ahora tengo
este 6 que me estorban este 6 lo voy a
pasar del otro lado
y para pasarlo del otro lado voy a
restar 6 de ambos lados de la ecuación
menos 6 aquí del lado izquierdo y menos
6 aquí del lado derecho
18 - seis es 12 estos dos se van 6 menos
60 y después me queda solamente 27
entonces 12 es igual a 2 james y ahora
bien si yo agarro y divido a ambos lados
entre 2 voy a obtener el valor de
jacques cousteau lo que quiero entre 2 y
entre 2 entonces que obtengo 12 entre 2
es lo mismo que 6 déjame ver si me cabe
aquí si se me cabe aquí 12 entre 2 y 6
estos dos se van y me queda decirles
sencillamente bien y entonces llévale 6
es decir que es justo lo que estoy
buscando en 6 años voy a obtener que
armando va a tener el triple de edad que
diana que es lo que yo quería por eso
había definido a mi incógnita como ya y
les seis años en cuántos años esté
hernando va a tener tres veces o el
triple de edad que gianna pues bueno la
respuesta 6 y qué va a pasar con las
edades seremos buenos preguntas no es
eso pues ya vale 6 entonces 18 + james
ojo
ya nos movimos 6 años 18 más y es lo
mismo que 18 + 6 lo cual es 24 entonces
armando va a tener 24 años mientras que
de ha nam
va a tener 26 porque lleva de 6 es decir
8 años en seis años armando va a tener
24 años y diana va a tener 8 y date
cuenta que 24 es el triple que 8 cuando
pasen seis años al mando va a tener 24
diana 8 y 24 es tres veces 8 y ya está